I don't know how to put me, I don't know if I should put myself in the middle or not.
This link's awful!
I don't know how to do it though, right?
I honestly don't know how to do it but we're doing it, we're doing it, it's fine, we'll
get there.
Wow, hi momay, hi replays!
Good morning, good evening, good afternoon, we thought you forgot us.
No, you know for a fact, I take like two freaking minutes to get my coffee tea, I've got a hot
water bottle with me today, I don't know if you can hear me, give a good spank.
I've got a hot water bottle on my tummy.
Hi!
Are you ready?
I was killed more than five minutes ago, I'm able to carry you again, let's go!
We aren't even going to play Elden Ring until like, I don't know, maybe August when we put
up Elden Ring again.
But good morning, good evening, good afternoon.
Today I'm going to show you the secret to making money, a good old ASMR collab, okay?
So on today's agendination, okay, I am going to write one-on-one collabs with none other
than the members of Vehler and Dolj, and before you're like, when do these drop, relax,
I've not even finished writing the damn thing, okay, relax, I don't want to see, when is
it, when does it drop, one, Amy's away on holiday, right, relax, two, AC's voice is
fucked, three, Mary's trying to move out, fucking, five, wait, no, four, Azura, Azura's
trying to move out, five, she be, she be fucking on Elden Ring, okay, she's doing endurance.
These girls ain't going to drop everything to get this shit done, it doesn't have to
be done right now, relax, I got ASMRs coming out of the wazoo, relax, okay, ooh, oh shit,
okay, I've already decided what mine and Amy's plot is, so I can just write out little,
well, I would actually be big sister, I'm also so big sister, because it's going on
my channel, so it's big sister and, like, the fancy and sign, nah, that's awful, and
little sister tingle you to sleep, that would be mine and Amy's plot, because if you didn't
know, if I had a lighter voice, it'd be fucking over for you lollipop lovers, your fucking
dick would explode, I'm doing a big sister and little sister club with Denpo, fuck,
fuck, right, okay, new plan, new plan, new plan, new plan, right, shit, I can't do a
lighter voice, do I, do I do two little sisters tingle you, fuck, what do I do, what do I
do, of course I fucking accidentally guessed what you're doing with someone else, shit,
who's the big sister, you're both wee, it's okay, it's step sister, so I can make it real
sisters for this one, aye, I knew it, yeah, I knew it, picture, right, that's amazing,
right, okay, we're doing, we're doing real big sister and real little sister, obviously
it makes no fucking sense, because one of us was randomly Scottish on the plot, but
hey ho, totally real for real for real, A.C., A.C. and Snowberries, thank you for joining
A.C. and Snowberries, I'm currently writing down the name of the plots that I'm forcing
the Vila members to create with me at a later date, right now, not right now, not right
now, that's what I'm trying to say, I've still pinned that I'm not live yet, but there's
a short on, Emmys rats, actually it was a really good short, girl friend and step sister,
of course, could we get away with that? I'm tempted, anonymous, hold on a minute, hold
on a minute, I'm kind of tempted, does the notification come up for that? That is kind
of genius, I feel like it's really taking the, I don't know, I'll put in brackets, I think
we're getting really fucking cruel, so I don't know how cheeky I'm feeling, step sister,
tingle, yum, I'll put in brackets that, okay, now for me and A.C., this is just an excuse
for me to get A.C. commissioned in a schoolgirl outfit, I'm sorry, I said what, I said Snowberries,
I don't give a fuck, okay, I wanted to do something like, it's an after school club,
and we're all three of us are forced into making this after school club, so we qualify
for the school not being mad at us for not doing an after school club, and then basically
we're like, well, well, it literally sounds park like, well, what are we doing there? What
are we doing there? And then it's just like, ooh, let's go through your phone, oh my god,
you freak of nature, wait, nature, you nasty boy, what is this? It's ASMR, oh my god, oh
my god, the shock, the horror, the lag deli, I'm basically a retinkler, right, so what's
that called? Is it Tussanderis? Tussanderis, wait, Tussanderis, find out, you like tingles,
so it's like alliteration, Tussanderis, detect, fuck, this has got a T in it, Tussanderis,
detect you, get tingles, it's a marker, wait, what's the T word that begins with detect,
to find out, to sleuth, wait, no, not the delay, I can't imagine AC as a Tussander, Tussanderis,
trace you, trace, trace you, get tingles, it's like, shut the fuck up, this is awful, Tussanderis
with an S, okay, that's all right, that's so scoff, right, okay, the next, I'll highlight
it in, I'll outline it in red so you guys can see what we're probably gonna work on,
thank you again anonymous for that tip, I've never even thanked ya, I was just like, thanks
anonymous for the idea, mine, as if you didn't just give me your worldly money, triangulate,
wait, Tussanderis, triangulate, stop, that's so funny, that you get tingles, that you get
tingles, okay, that's good, I'm taking that, right, mercy, should I pick mercy, oh sugar,
I'm in the way a little bit, hold on, I'm sorry chat, chat, can my hair go on you a little bit,
it was mercy to geese practice their honking ASMR, honestly, I uploaded a short that someone made,
that short that was made was someone's submission that they're good enough to edit, like shorts in
general, and management sent it on to me and I was like, wait, who edited that, because that's
not in the editing style of who got on board, and they were like, no, this is someone submitting
themselves to be an editor, and I'm like, wait, they did this for free, like, obviously we paid
them, but it's very rare to ever get an example of work, via an actual example of work on your
content, so yeah, smell the laughter, I'm already right, what are we doing with the yandere, are
we becoming yandere too, I really wish it wasn't offensive, but obviously both me and
mercy's lore eventually you perish in it, and it would be kind of funny to do like a you perish
in the end of it, Scottish, Scottish laughter, I don't have an accent when I'm Scottish laughing,
that doesn't make sense, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, what the, no, that's not a thing,
you want to hear yandere lines with a Scottish accent, I thought you said that I was your yandere,
wait, how about what, like two yandere's confused on who the real, no, because then we're like
arguing with each other, that's not relaxing, both of us are like, listen up you slag,
this is how the facts are, see that guy right there, he belongs to me, I'm the yandere in this
situation, no, that's not going to put anyone to sleep, okay, let us tingle, no, it's not going
to put anyone to sleep, two girls make you comfy until the darkness, oh, okay, some of you have
your tastes, we're not quite there, ASMR Viking funeral, oh my god, oh wait, how about a sleep aid,
hear me out, a sleep aid, but it's yanderefied, okay, so yandere tied up, sleep aid, and I'll get
an artwork of you being tethered to me and mercy in bed, and like, it's like basement, like ambience,
ASMR, you can hear it's like breathing in your ear, and we're doing like some sleep talking, we're like,
oh you senpai, you're always ours, whatever, like that kind of thing, so like you can hear like
basement jingle, and then like the little furnace goes on in the corner, because that's where the
furnace thingy is kept in a house, I don't know, two yandere's take care of their pet human, that's
actually gonna most likely end up in more clicks, so let me just steal that too, yandere's, I've lost
it, two yandere's take care of the pet human, okay, and then sheepsters, this is not sheepsters,
this is azura, right, azura was going to be a sleep aid as well, but my problem is the artwork,
I wanted to get artwork where you are embraced by the both of us at a certain location,
two crazy cultists, for me and merchie, two mommies, yandere flashes, oh sorry,
sorry, I just made that word up, but there's not even, hold on, I'm gonna drink my tea,
because it's gonna get cold, if azura embraces us, she embraces you too technically, honestly,
I get swallowed up alongside, I'd be like, hold on a minute, aren't I supposed to be doing the
freaking tingling, goddesses, fuck it, let's both be goddesses, I'll get myself drawn with
like body paint and that, goddesses, like sleep aid ASMR, sleep aid ASMR, oh no, thank you Oregon
for the vibe, wait do you guys actually want yandere's Scottish ASMR, like a solo, I'll do it,
what did you say, if I find out you're fucking cheating Senpai, I'll kick your fucking cunt in,
honestly, you want that, okay, okay, okay, I'll gie you, I'll gie you, let me kick, let me kick,
I would have to whisper it so fast though, I'll be like, I'm gonna fucking kick that cunt in,
I swear I'm going Senpai, you're supposed to only be for me, so where the fuck is
I'm gonna go in your social media, I can see you following all these other
like, I would have to whisper it so fast, should I do that, like the fastest whisper, like yandere
Scottish ASMR, like a muster, mommy being mean to us, oh I'm not normally mean but, goddess is
pamper, goddess is pamper, they're servant to sleep ASMR, I don't know, okay, as long as it's a
work in progress, don't wait, who goes there, identify yourself, are you squiddin' me right now,
a goat goddess and a sea goddess, Brian, wow Brian, you said that so fast, I don't know why
my brain couldn't really keep up, thank you for your love for the five, how about that, I don't,
so lower wise that doesn't make any sense, because as there is your mohen, does your,
does every audio have to be whispers, no, but if I'm like straight up bit posting then I do,
I do like to say it's not ASMR, but if we are gonna slap ASMR, you can do soft spoken ASMR,
that's actually true, very true, Freya did fantastic soft spoken ASMR collab, that's coming out
soon TM, oh be friends, I got an eight hour sleep, because I hired a maid, so my location
is in a disarray and I don't want my dad to see it before he comes over, so I had to stay awake
for this lovely maid to come over and I was passing out in my little gamer chair, I was like
when you're finished please just come on through, I'm just doing some work,
and yeah she likes me, because she said you've clearly never hired a maid before,
I don't know, I don't know if I said this story from last time or not, I can't remember,
but basically are we talking asmongold room untidy, no, no, no food, no mold, none of this stuff,
just like it's a mess and I need help type stuff, a normal maid or a naughty maid, well considering
the host is clean, I'm gonna say a normal maid, she being strongly tried to lure you into the
respective domains, Wonderland or sorry, oh what would you pick, a nice warm hotel or a cold,
freezing cold cave, even I'm picking Wonderland, but where will the rats live, it's any who has
rats, are you saying for me to get a pet rat, I wish I could get a pet rat but they have very
limited lifespans and I can't handle it, I cannot handle it, you picking the cave because of hypnosis,
okay right sheepsters, right me and a rabbit, what would me and a rabbit do when we get together
is the question, hmm, wait I'm halfway finished with tea, what would me and she be do, hmm,
office worker, you want like an office worker meme, HR training ASMR, oh my god it will go like
completely meme route, HR, you have to be HR trained ASMR, question mark or is that two Mimi,
double domination is fun, goddess is reward and somnatic followers for their devotion to
sleep ASMR, oh this is good, when you collab with Mercy do the mickey mouse, no, it's because I can't
do Mercy's voice, don't do ironic jokeies, no do I run, don't, I run a jokeies one, two office ladies
and you do overtime, that sounds like an alternative plot line I'm gonna be honest, how do I make it
back to wholesome, the only way I can make that back to wholesome hold on
angel and devil on your shoulders, one whispers negative affirmations, the other whispers positive
affirmations, that is so mean, because then who's the bad guy, I can be your angel or your devil,
ASMR, I mean on shibi made like that because she mentioned the meme,
shibi a baddie, thank you so much Anonymous for the tip,
wait I just stole something what did I steal, it's so tiny what did I steal,
hold on let me let me make it big and let me make it readable, nope that was a highlight I
didn't mean to do that, hold on wait hold on, I'll show you this, two office ladies and you do
overtime, right now let's, if I was to expand on this one this is quite easy to do because it
would be the classic, oh my god you look so tired XD and then that's when you confess you have not
slipping at all and then we go oh no we must help for you at once, ASMR continues, listener falls
a sweep, no a sweep, all is good in the world, amen, that would be how that plot would go,
if we did too, I think HR trained, I think HR trained is more of a meme solo plot to be honest
that's not really although, decisions how I want them all, I can't get them, I want to eat the whole
cake, I'm not sharing, I'm not sharing, anyone listen to Borg or, oh it's been a many a year,
you can't keep doing overtime if you aren't well rested, okay okay yeah yeah because we're still
we're still office kind of things in here, okay okay this, I know it looks terrible, just relax,
relax, okay so we've got the ideas done about what we're gonna type okay so and then we just get
let's get to it, so basically break them up, break them up, give them a little room, give them a
little space, so this is what actually happens behind the scenes, so just pretend I am sending
Emmy a script okay, so this is what Emmy will see, first thing she will be greeted by is the title
of the plot so she understands what kind of thing is about to go down, now if you really want you
can also give a premise, I don't necessarily always write a premise but because the title's so
explanatory there's no need for it, this is the key part okay, this is the key part
and you're not ready for it, I write this in every collab script and it doesn't work
please, well we're not going to do it at this, oh maybe we should please
whisper through the whole script, now I know this might seem crazy to have this so big and so
center, I cannot tell you how many collab scripts I've sent away, what is this, are you explaining
your job, I am showing you how to make infinite money glitch on YouTube, you're welcome
so this always gets ignored without fail and it's fine, I'm used to it, so if I ever get a
script back and like I'm whispering but the other person isn't, it always happens, it's fine, I'm
used to it, I don't get mad or anything, I don't ask the girl to redo the lines either because it
takes a lot of time especially when really in this exchange the only exchange happening is like
hey can I put an ASMR on my YouTube channel so the exchange isn't that good of an exchange rate
okay, please whisper, well you want me to whisper right now or do you mean like I like begging them
so normally you are supposed to start off your own script by yourself to have the guest, the guest
person that is going to show up on your channel start is not wrong, it's not a negative if they
do, I mean heck the plot might evolve quite well if you were to but you want to give your collab
partner less work than what you do, that makes sense, you know if you're going for a straight 50-50
on words then sure go for it but you never really want to make them in the trouble, Dumbledore said
can't we, hi, did you put your name in a cup? okay so
okay I've almost finished my tea, there's a bubble in my tea, I must have put a bubble in it
Dr. Crush tries to give you migraine relief, Dr. Crush, get it, reindeer listener
what does that mean? ASMR is begging you to whisper in a collab ASMR please, please read the start
oh actually I should explain the difference between
me, it's strongy, here is the new collab script, the title is we kiss and make out for 10 minutes
straight, let me know what you think, anonymous, one you're wrong for that, two that's hilarious
that's terrible, that's terrible, no you cannot send a script away asking for 10 minutes of kissing
sounds okay and then call it ASMR, you'll get limited ads and it'll be suppressed like heck
although it'd be really funny to do like six girls kissing ASMR and then when you click on it I was
like careful you're not to jerk your pintas to death or something right strongy right what's the
plot real big sister and real little sister tingly asleep right what are we doing are we creeping
into your bedroom or do you give us a cheeky text saying you can't sleep or are we already in your
bedroom or do we need to make our way to your bedroom slurping raman ASMR feed the void what
it wants mother and the fire everyone please kiss throughout the whole script 10 minutes
okay we're gonna creep into the bedroom okay so i'm gonna remind emmy remember we have to be super
dooper quiet we're not supposed to be out of bed right now but
however wait okay wait remember we have to be super super quiet oh actually here's an example so
this is just me regularly talking you can start an ASMR regularly talking but then you can also
do what's called soft spoken ASMR when you're the thumb in your voice is still present so you see
that uh that's what i call thumb from skyrim uh you can continue to do that with soft spoken so
i can get closer to you but you can still hear the uh and my voice this is soft spoken ASMR
that's how it'd be and then whispering ASMR when there is no thumb present in your voice at all
you hear the uh when i whisper what do you know there's absolutely no well i would have to retake
that line for example but as i whisper and there should be no thumb present i constantly have to
retake lines when i whisper because i have quite a voice so yeah little sister breaks down your
door remember we have to be super dooper quiet we're not supposed to be out of bed right now
i don't want to i don't want to get caught because i'll i'll end up getting more chores just to
really set the whole our parents are asleep in bed plot okay i don't want to end up getting more
chores i don't want to get caught because i'll end up getting more chores uh as their fucking birds
are going wild um i want to get caught because i'll end up getting more chores does that make sense
wait hold on let me recalibrate remember we have to be super dooper quiet we're not
supposed to be at bed right now i don't want to get caught because is it because i've said
a slang term which is because i'll end up getting more chores you you always get a waste
is it scott free get it because i'm scottish oh shit is my soundboard not up hold on
shit my soundboard hold on pause right was it stream deck hold on hold on hold that thought
what was the joke i've already forgotten it right i'm ready i'm ready for the joke um
you always get a waste scott free get it because i'm scottish
thank you thank you i'll be here a week
get it scottie okay i'm sorry it was bad thank you again and on this for the tip
of your making out sessions but you all you always get a waste scott free
i don't want to be like because i'm because i'm the parents favorite no that's not nice
let's not say that i mean um you're the only one laughing here
what do you mean that joke was terrible it's funny because scott is uh both a noun and a verb
yeah a verb is a doing word a noun is a naming word an adjective is a describing word there you go
a little bit of english for you that's how i remember you always get a waste scott free
it's because i know exactly what to say and what they want to hear
because emi's so emi's a wee smartical thing it's because i know exactly what to say and
what they want to hear you have to think past what they immediately want you to do
you realize that right dammit anyway let's not get caught up in that right now let's not get caught
up in theories right now we're outside his door let's go in then then are you ready for this part
are you ready for this part this is truly a behind the scenes moment door open dot mp3
that's right i've written where i need to put sound effects in case i forget that is super
duper top secret information when it comes to writing ASMR collabs do a little footsteps oh
you want foots it's so hard to get footsteps ASMR that isn't like terrible right footsteps
dot mp3 bed rustling dot mp3 okay and then this is when this is when this gets really complicated
okay strongy yes you take whispering in the left ear from now on do you understand yes emi
i'm sorry emi you take whispering in the right ear from now on dammit myself clear
okay thank you i'm so sorry i can't hear your voice um unzip dot mp3 not this kind of script not
this kind of script okay um i think i know right so now we are next to you on the bed okay
by the pope who goes there identify yourself friend
script idea a guy goes to bed after watching all blue girl's streams and wakes up to see
all six in his room proceeds to tingle him to make him choose who his oh she is all that's an
interesting one can i spoil a collab that is a an ASMR collab question mark that is going on
someone else's channel with all six of us can i ruin that for you guys thank you anonymous for the
tip i'm at loud squeaky floorboard dot mp3 oh you want that one okay there's a collab going on a certain
dream of pages um you uh v youtuber slash youtuber when vtuber uh ASMR channel
can i tell i'm gonna i'm gonna ruin what the plot is so close your ear holes if you don't want to
close your eardrums no don't let any air vibrations get to your eardrums for the next two minutes
um the plot is uh we you couldn't get home after a vtuber convention so you slept with
seven of us in a hotel room and basically you didn't sleep well enough so we tingle you one by one
it was a bit difficult to write i'll be honest that plot that you've just said to me anonymous
is a lot better um to choose who an oh she is yeah i feel like when it comes to me i'll be like
don't worry i wouldn't pick me either anyway here's ear muffs let me just put these on you real quick
then i tingle tingle together i know what you mean i know what you mean um sorry i'm addicted to you
kind of stop your vibrations i need them yeah so that is a plot that's coming out soon tm i actually
just need to edit together then i think it's ready to kind of get wapped up uh one by one we tingle
yes um right strawney whispering in left ear
surprise did you miss us i saw that you were online a few minutes ago on discord so we
uh came through because we know you're having uh a tough time sleeping i have even better news
little emmers that's right that's my nickname for her everyone got a nickname before i even met them
um emmy is emmers isis uh icicle or ice uh sheby sheepsters um as they're never got one because
her name is so nice like i never really gave her a nickname mercy i guess i'll just sing her name
really mercy i only had we mercy for a little bit obviously because mercy's name was not mercy all the
time shebity tight okay you're done you're getting timed out for that can i time you out for that hold
on i can't time you out give like oh no i can't time you out god damn it i'm gonna time you out for
10 seconds for the meme if you like my idea you can take the idea if you want to oh thank you
would make me happy that i helped my favorite streamer come up with a script i can't promise it's
coming up anytime soon it takes me a while to cook okay as you can see by how long it's taken me
to do any a smarts recently uh yes emmy acy wasi azure's sheepsters mercers cuddles he lives from
it mods put that wifling in the milk i saw him dying in front of me as he as he's like what uh an
australian gives a nickname to like aza that would be it she's a tyrant thank you again for the
type anonymous yes i made yoink that idea just understand i should have like a big to s warning
i will steal your ideas at will and take credit there there's the warning i'll just put it in
the middle of my name every script why not why not um okay whispering surprise did you miss
i saw you were online a few minutes ago on discord so i came through because we know you're
having a tough time sleeping we have even better news little emmers decided to get i don't know i
want to be like she pickpocketed some sheet of someone but right little emmers i found some tools
that might be really useful for putting you to sleep what do you think and then emmy's like
stolen fevery no even though it clearly was she yanked them off like another
god i don't know some other kid maybe she summoned them from the world you cannot steal
that which we offer freely i mean is the whole point of this kind of stream to take suggestions yeah
please steal my thoughts of my money off me then okay i'll i'll take the thoughts keep the money
though buy yourself a pastry buy yourself a greg some of that cheese and onion a baguette let's go
hey no not cheese and onion cheese and a hamburger that with that gelatinous ham i remember
one of the hams fell out and i like inspected under the light things bloody see-through they
couldn't have made it any thinner if they wanted to uh i simply borrowed them pulls out a hammer
to beat you with i mean emmy probably could make that uh idea how about instead of having a tough
sleep the listeners is having a hard time sleeping i saw you on so we came through because we know
you're having uh hard time sleeping whoa why did i say it like that who knows um
have even better news a lot of embers found some tools that could be really useful putting it
asleep what do you think what what do you mean where did i get them from stop it no she's not
gonna batter them but well what do you mean where did i get them from i sourced them i sourced them
was it ethically eth ethically you don't have to worry so much about me brother
brother fuck macho man rendy savage you're in here with me brother you don't stand a chance
against the tingles i like the way you think emmy's a little thief she's a mischievous little thing
okay big brother are you implying i i procured them through scrupulous unscrupulous means
should i do that should i make emmy's words like really articulate and then mine just like basic
slang are you mean where did i get i sourced them ethically okay wait hold on i just like
straight up yonk to sentence ah that's the only thing i hate about yonkin sentences is for some
reason it does not like it are you implying are you implying that i produced them through
unscrupulous means you don't have to worry so much about me brother laughter see so i can't
replicate a laugh for any of the girls so when i give them like a bracket like that they must
follow it or it gets completely taken out of the script um obviously i can't go like i don't
know where the fuck emmy laughs like i think she goes i think she's a bit like that ethically
sourcents unethically someone cringe greedy streamer versus giga chad buy yourself food mummy
i acquired them from a generous patron yes the fact she is even little makes it hilarious
she's a wrestling fan please do ASMR like that snapping into a slim gym it's macho man randy
savage that my voice would be gone within a millisecond but you don't have to worry so much
about me brother okay so the good thing about this kind of ASMR is it really doesn't have to be that
long at all hold on let's get that let's get that word count in so we've got 83 words do you know what
that means it means almost two minutes of dialogue i'll teach you a little trick so 100 words normally
equals one minute of dialogue but there's an exception to this rule which is whispering
whispering extends dialogue dramatically it it completely flips it on its head because when
you whisper duggle remember we have to be super duper quiet we're not supposed to be out of bed
right now i don't want to be no that's not relaxing strongy hold on that's not relaxing so i have to
go remember let's be super duper quiet okay we're not supposed to be out of bed right now which is
a lot faster than going remember we've got to be super duper quiet we're not supposed to be out of
bed right now okay so whispering is always an exception to the the unwritten rule that normally
a hundred words equals a minute whispering extends yes completely it means you need to add more big
brother findom appreciators and shambles thankfully i don't care for findom yeah i'm not i need to yeah
yeah remember remember the 5th of november we're gonna blow up parliament uh i was out of context
for the 5th of november um that is a memorial date where guy fox's plot failed uh some nations
celebrate the failure other nations scorned uh like to celebrate the attempt um but you know
that is just how easy it is what it is strongy's plot this girlfriend begs you for five dollars so
she can gamble on on voucher room honestly felt that right we're not doing i see i see you pop down
there we're not doing you right now okay right whispering what do you mean where did i get them
from are you implying i produced them through unscrupulous means you don't have to worry about
me so you don't have to worry so much about me big brother laughter you know you know i can take care
myself you view no i see who emi's like emi's this but i see who you know ten out of ten
impression we were robbed of the good ending guy fox mentioned live on stream emi yanked them
from her pay piggies in school oh my god do you think emi would do that emi would have like some
em instead of like giving your lunch money
feeling give me this right okay um i just realized oh no it's too big hold on there we go
you know i can take care of myself now why don't you get comfy and we can have a sleep over as well
tonight i don't care if we get in trouble again
i never sleep better unless it's all three of us together oh my god emi with the heart of gold right
okay emi's got a heart of gold right next unfortunately i'm gonna have to do it like this
stronzo emi's i was actually gonna write emi's um so now that we've kind of set up the plot
so again i'll just kind of quickly go over it so this is what emi's gonna see when i send her
she's not gonna see all of this like notes this is like this is a different document i'll send her
a different google doc link so she's gonna see the title she's gonna see please whisper please i'm on
minis um so we're in we're talking in the middle of the microphone here um i'll just put a little
middle i mean i think emi's pretty familiar with how i write scripts at this point in time i mean
they all are because they were forced to use my terrible scripts for a little while but thank
god they don't have to anymore um so the plot is we're outside your room um we noticed we don't
want to get caught because parents bad um but emi's got some tools and knows how to get it because
she's just so amazing she knows how to get out and then we go inside your room right now brian
and she's gonna see let's make out for 10 minutes brian no anonymous no we're not gonna make out
the freaking title the title is real big sister and real little sister
and on you've got some tastes she says as she created emi in her own image you've got some
jet you've got some tastes okay now here's the fun part here's the fun part so we've set up the
plot we're in bed we're all gonna sleep together right so i'll actually i'm gonna ask emi for
five minutes of soft breathing five minutes of soft breathing in the ear ASMR please but don't
do like too much breathing that it becomes ear breathing ear blowing ASMR you know what i mean
emi oh i just realized you can't hardly see that there you know what i mean emi there you can
kind of see there that ain't move over but i don't want to be like humping chat well hold on a minute
okay spoke a little bit too soon um right so this is me asking emi for soft breathing because
at the end we're both gonna pass out okay um strong so you too i need five minutes soft
breathing but i know what i mean when i say that so it doesn't come you don't okay let's compromise
for six minutes of making out this is terrible right this is where the fun part comes in what
what do you what tingles do you want us to do to you hmm or do you want us to do tingles at the
same time so like i'll do like i don't know ear cupping and then emi's like i'll do finger fluttering
you want hair brushing how about hair brushing and hair play we can do like two at the same time
or do you want one ear difference like for example i can do ear tapping and then emi can do ear
blowing um and then i can do like i don't know scrunching something against your ear i mean there's
a few but if you want safer work how about sniffing brav sniffing is the market's limited ads any kind
of fucking breathing orientated shite is like getting absolutely hammered right now i think it
should be one at a time okay you want one at a time should we do should we do dual wheeled heartbeat
oh uh uh dual wheeled heartbeat somewhere though i don't know oh it'd be fun if you did hair
brushing and hair play at the same time warm breathing into our ears as if our ears were
cold and you had to warm them up like that is that what you want you want golem i'm joking i
know what you mean thank you anonymous okay um right i'll do warm breathing uh ear ASMR
i'll get emi's to do cold blowing which is it right i don't know if we'll finally stop talking at
this point hold on uh right let me just think uh right i never sleep better unless it's all three
of us together i want to be like you're such a souk emi but i don't think you guys say souk the
way we say souk if i say to emi you're such a souk it just means she really likes her big brother
which is my little brother in the plot because i'm the big sister yeah you're i don't think you
say souk in anywhere else but it basically just means that emi really likes brother
rare metro man randy savage a souk a sucker no em a souk means
it's like slang for you you just really like them i've never heard of the word souk right
let's take that out then because literally no one's gonna get it um you're such a i don't want to be
like the word doesn't suck up that's not the word it's that's a different word souk sounds different
here what do you think of some fabric sounds i don't mean in the naughty way but like a blanket
oh yeah yeah blanket rustling ASMR yeah i've got that um brocon would be better no no that's that's
not how it works both you and emi warm breathing first then both you and emi cold breathing after
i mean i can get that dude uh the only problem is it's gonna come be a bit of a headache for emi
if i'm asking her to do all these different sound effects
all right hold on what is an anonymous one uh thank you for the tip uh both you and emi want
warm breathing right okay fuck it we'll do warm breathing together take that out you you're such a
emi okay good sense you want to try again maybe i don't know have a have another shot okay first
we are going to warm your ears up cut because i can already tell you're freezing in here that's why
it's it's better we stick together because because because more strongy that's why it's better we
stick together because we can look after you after you and in turn your extra no that should
get rid of that yeah see this is like live correcting myself like oh that's a terrible
sentence get out of here clingy oh clingy yeah clingy it would work warm breathing is a put
okay so um so when you do your blowing ASMR it's like your your lips are pierced together and like
as if you were gonna whistle okay so it's like oh sorry sorry i didn't mean to whistle sorry um
it's like like that but if you want to warm someone's ears up i have to open my mouth and go
you know um so that's the difference between those two tingles and especially in the three
video is a very big difference you can you can hear the unwanted whistle whistle ASMR when
right fucking now oh my god i'm the wind i'm the i'm the cold wind rushing past your window right
now um okay first we're gonna warm up your ears because i'm going to tell you you're freezing
in here that's why it's better we stick together because we can look in after you so then both
me and emmer emmer oh no don't start that brain please don't me and emmy are gonna do
and then emmy's gonna go see isn't that better already
aren't aren't you glad she spotted you lurking on discord that's right because he has both of them
i i was actually asleep already but i what the fuck are you trying to say out with it i was
actually asleep wait no i was i can't say already see isn't that better already aren't you glad she
spotted you lurking on discord discord i'm running out of time i don't know where the words are
no no no no no no no no who are you snow white
cold breath hot soup warm breath freezing hands wow that is the most simplest way to
describe it and i've never even fucking came close man i can only kind of whistle by sucking it in
the air oh you can do it both ways i think i can do it both ways hold on let me let me get the old
lip lips wet and let me wet my whistle that's in and out i can do it
yeah you like that whispering howling at the moon what we're gonna turn the
fucking werewolves in a minute the fuck is going on in this plot
we'll break up our human skin and uh just fucking i don't know what are werewolves like
your robes yeah having to deal with my werewolf sisters asmr and we just start panting when we
get your robes isn't that better now i was already asleep already isn't so you're not
peeing isn't that better now okay have a laugh isn't that better now isn't that better now
better now this is actually funny what i was already asleep but oh oh it's my time for music
because you pen pals i know you're out there and i know you like being called big brother
so don't think i'm not getting any notice say these words for nothing
i'm on to you pin pals you better look after her when she gets back that i made myself clear
good right how the fuck does my asmr come with a warning
um right okay isn't that better now so we're both kind of doing that so we're gonna highlight a
tingle just so we know where we're kind of that's a terrible highlight highlight the nation right
just fucking make it bright fuck it wow okay that's bright enough uh right so we'll do that
and then that's that section so what's the next tingle um yes mine can you put some secret hidden
muffling in playing we're doing what exactly
what did he say we're on the same level but no i could do bed rustling sounds how about that
where's the part where you make it well we all know who the anonymous is don't know what it is now
crystal clear we'll spoil her rotten when she gets back damn straight
a stern voice strawney like i didn't talk like that ever but i always make an exception when i'm
talking about my daughter's the warm breath leading the sweat and so everybody removes their
clothes no it's strawney you can call us darlin in the script you want to be called darlin
oh but you're my brother in the script i'm not sure i can get away with that without it being
a bit odd but a bit strange eh right who wants the next what's the next tingle
we've done warm breathing asmr so now you're nice and warm so what we kill you down with what
fucking joe wield asmr how about we both do strawney and i mean we do the face wipe and the
fucking bloop bloop bloop what are they called bloop bloop things you want eyes what is this
one about i overslept um i'm writing my one-on-one script with emmy and it's called real big sister
and real little sister tingle you to sleep asmr okay um bloop bloop bloop
uh head scratchers left ear rubs right um possibly the ice globes are amazing little sister and
no wait what you thought what we are oh you did see it i was gonna say how did you see that i thought
it was an eep snubbed kind reminder the girlfriend and step sister has also
been rejected instead of little and big sister we can't do that that no we've already committed
to sister maybe another day how about another day what about i'll make it a bonus on go even
about i'll make it like one dollar so it's like confirmed thank you again anonymous for the tip
that's funny as fuck right what did what is it the crack pipes oh we love the crack pipes the bloop
bloop right okay so we've just hit you up we need to kill you down now okay so we're gonna kill you
down with face wipes and bloop bloop okay so oh god that's gonna be the combo what the fuck are we
gonna say though okay right so then i'll say then you want you to be too hot xd oh why is it blue
no don't do that and then emmy will be like xd okay how about i'll ask her about the
thievery of the items that we're using okay we don't want you to get too hot now so let's do some
cooling things that should help lull your ass to sleep help lull wait is that how you spell lull
help the one dutch person going absolutely nuts in the chat right now oh because i've spelled it
like that let us hit what some cooling things that should help lull you to sleep is that not a word
oh it's got an extra l of course it has an extra l the what of the what sorry
emmy they won't stop suggestion that we randomly make out in this like so we do the fill collab and
then at the end they want 10 minutes of making out and i'm like i'm like me like what the title is
literally real big sister and real little sister tingles you oh my god let's do it no the fuck
said you're not to encourage them emmy you're not to encourage them i'm already out in a
pale battle literally i'm like no we can't do it i can't be done like that
oh i'm making out with my mosa and our club oh for fuck's sake all right that's fine wait but
you're not you're not sisters in the club are you please tell me you're not sisters in the club
please i'm on my hands and knees please tell me emmy you know we're not okay that's fine okay you
can make it in general then that's fine how about you how about you in our case uh i cannot i can't
recommend you to the plot i can't be done uh thanks for encouraging it as long as we wear socks it's
fine okay stroney you're fighting a war alone if you think she was gonna say no what if they made
out with one of our ears and their tongues met in the middle all right yous are done yous are done
yous are getting too creative right we're doing face wipes and bloop bloop bloop bloop ASMR okay we
don't want you to get too hot now so let's do some cooling things that should help loli to sleep
i've got some of these face wipes that should help emmy seems to have some weird i swear god if
this is about making out for the local app little sister older step sister cousin girlfriend
girlfriend's friend and stepmother happy birthday reflitting oh what what did he say
wait who's who hold on hold on let me let me copy and paste it thank you anonymous for the tip
um this is gonna be such a mess when i send it to emmy what did you say what did he say
little sister right so that's emmy make it orange older step sister that must be icicle
cousin is mercy girlfriend me girlfriend's friend she be
and then step mummy which is her she's technically teal oh my f**k it won't look at that
that is that the order does that look great your aren't it birthday collab where the whole
family makes it with each other emmy you're not to encourage this oh my god every time i look up
you see sun more cars i'm trying not to get anyone banned that'd be great that'd be great don't
ban thank you unknown all at once family get basically i mean we could unironically just
make this like a six six man kissing collab and you just hear is like layered kissing ASMR but
i couldn't i couldn't call it any of this yes just make a mom is my girlfriend see you nerd
i should have a convention enthusiast
okay sweet home i'm just gonna leave that in the middle of the club that's fine just pop that
down there thank you anonymous again for the tip that was very generous of you emmy's really
speaking for the reef ones right now she's speaking for the pin pals the f**king strawberries
the wait did i not make that purple oh it's purple it's just coming up that way um insert charlie's
let's go emmy stands by our side she's speaking for everyone weird i wonder why the girl you hired
for your invest kink would make jokes about oh right okay okay okay okay okay hold on a minute
now hold on a minute now hold on a minute now i'm not getting right okay i've got somebody's face
emmy seems to have some weird um face i don't know what how do you even call the contraption
that the bloop things are emmy seems to have i'm gonna put i'm gonna say the word scored
emmy seems to have scored some weird uh water thing wow that's a really good sentence you
should become a script writer yeah shut the f**k up um that's a terrible sentence i'll come back
to it okay it's hard to do things live my my brain so small facial massager okay yeah thank you i
think they are facial massasagers they are and i didn't score them they just belong to me now
oh emmy our little our little thief is that thieving if you think it should belong to you
because the person isn't using them anymore they come up as a facial massager's okay full on face
cleaning spa they fell from a trick toy ice toy idea courtesy of dempa bruh dempa really uh went
all out sadly it didn't get removed um but i think she enjoyed herself that's the main thing
sucking on icis more from icwin is she got no azura emmy and i all have a warning on our youtube
channels somehow yeah well not somehow i know how i got it i know i did wrong um yeah in the script
can you tell emmy you love her yeah of course how about that right i'll make an exception how about
the end of the script we all say good night to each other and give each other a family kiss
how about that right this is at the ending section okay so i go i don't think i've got
anything more in me i hope you are ready to fall asleep because i know i am let me lie
let let us lie down and get comfy beside you uh you're so warm under these covers that's like a
nice little comment and then um okay good night don't let the bed bugs bay love you lots brother
and emmy that doesn't that doesn't really work love love you both lots little forehead kisses
and then emory girls emmy gauze and
let make her all mumbling cute because she's so cute and fucking adorable and squeezable
fuck you emmy for being so cute god damn mumbly cute um i was falling asleep too but i didn't
want to say anything okay and then emmy i'm the bed bug oh for fuck's sake that should be kind
of funny i don't know how i could do that good compromise yes a family kiss is where you give
each other a family kiss the pentails would do that wait so all three of us are falling asleep
in the bed yes all three of us are together in bed and we're going to sleep and we're just
going to be a little bit of a sleep aid at the end i may add like rain the rain comes on and it's
just gently pitter pattering outside the window i love a good bit of rain and a smart plot but i
wouldn't do it during i would only be like oh the rain the rain just came on mm i was falling
asleep too but i didn't want to say anything what what exactly do you want me to say i love you too
you want to say that or just i love you i love you and then
family two whole family kisses like that part two on twitter right you're done you're done
you're getting rolled in smoke they could be killing him off because he's getting too hot
having both step sisters pressed against him i want to see you know step in this house
i'll see no step in this house we don't do uh not from around here partner we don't do step
around here not around these parts you want emmy to say i love you in timo's voice
i love you like this having both blood related sister he's also blood related
wouldn't you make the rain in the background make more sense for cooling down mid audio
i'll see i don't really i don't know when to shove the rain in
our family tree is a circle
it's a fucking roundabout at the rate it's heading
eh they're right what are we doing looping okay they're they're they are and i didn't
they are as implying their facial massagers they are and i didn't score them they just
belong to me now why not focus on how refreshing i don't know why refreshing they are on your face
and the looping around you instead of thinking about the little detail the
little details that don't matter that's probably why you can't sleep dummy
you oh my god please oh my god the english please you just need to tune the world out
and focus on both of us of both your sisters pampering you to sleep okay hold on what the
fuck was this word supposed to be okay i've got there in the end we got there in the end i love
hearing dummy in role plays yeah you're welcome this is probably why you can't sleep dummy
but i'm your girlfriend and she's your step sister and on the best part and
not brian you're not even supposed to encourage it anon that's terrible that's a lot of money
as well what the fuck i don't i can never tell if it's the same anon over and over but i swear
god you're spending a lot of fucking money in meme i'm your girlfriend she's your step sister
that's a bit bruv that video would get whipped off so quick soz we'd both end up with spanking
reminds me of a great german song called mine stab him is in christ i can't read german i'm sorry
if one opens the window mid audio then you can insert your sweaty feet tapping on floor mp3
i need to record that actually oh the kitchen floor is all clean now thanks to my maid um
and before anyone's like we are anon
okay thank you anonymous for the tip we are anon we are the borg do not be assimilated
we are anon become girlfriend and uh step sister
seeing brother who do you like better bigger little sisters kisses right yous are actually
done we can't even get through i don't know if we should move on to the next one because
yous are getting in trouble but right we've got face wipes so you're cooled down now okay
what's the next tingle that we're gonna do
what's the next combination you want we are alabama anon honestly
such a big wig corporal vtuber hires maids oh honestly i felt really weird i didn't like it but
my dad's coming over and i'm so sorry but i just don't have time to clean like i genuinely don't
like everything's a fucking state in a mess and i was like fuck it i'm just gonna have to do it
honestly it was actually really fucking cheap um she was in for two hours and it was
um for someone to do manual labor for two hours like cleaning up and like up after all my shite in
that um no not my literal shite i actually uh i'll say no no i didn't make her clean my toilet
because i don't like doing that that's not nice like i i did it myself i like fucking said
there i was like didn't clean the toilet i'll i'll actually cry please don't do it and
the there she's like probably like uh uh uh have you really blown the fucking thing out and
it's like no i just don't like the idea of you cleaning that because that's not nice to do to
anyone remember it is always morally correct to kiss your sister stop me not you're done right
you're done we're moving on to the next script this is getting out fucking regions right we're
doing two we're doing two two sundries triangulate that you get tingles ASMR you guys are actually
thank you for the tip and the generosity oh my god i've got you guys so pent up it's a freaking
wholesome script we're literally just trying to put you to sleep as well like oh my god you guys
are so pent up do you need help do you need help like you're so pent up in the morning is it
because it's first thing in the morning oh yes we need help always pin pals and every band from
shoni's chat no you're not banned but like i'm trying to get through one script idea and it's like
let's make it for 10 minutes oh yeah testosterone's peak in the morning it's 3 p.m est is that still
technically morning put us to sleep we're getting killed no to sleep sleep like ASMR sleep oh my god
in some ways the pin pals are keeping hard by like a lot let's do the script step by step is that
fucking is that a step sister joke pretty sure we are trolling unless the pin pals are suffering
from an MA deficiency no i know exactly what the pin pals and embers have been up to don't think i don't
know that both of you's made an agreement a two weeks i'd be two weeks two whole weeks on both parties
yeah i'm not surprised you guys are in here asking for kissing make out ASMR two weeks that's what you
get two two two sander's triangulate that you get tingles ASMR well well if we're going to make
this group work we have to convince them we actually hang out there's no all right remember this plot
is just an excuse for me to get ac in a drawn in a school uniform okay that's what i'm going
i said it i said it shoni why do you pronounce to sunday like that oh shit too san dairy oh is
it not how you say to to sunday so yandere to sunday as it's not that it's like sunday oh no
to is is sin oh it's sunday wait no my alliteration it has to be with the tea the tea is silent no my
alliteration the tea is silent why with the tv silent to sunday's triangulate that you get tingles
my alliteration no sorry it's called to sunday's triangulate no wait you said this all your life
yeah i just thought it was tea it's called tea why don't you put a tea in it if the tea doesn't belong
there words are hard oh my god everyone billy to sunday it's not the tea is not silent yeah i thought
it was to sunday alliteration no i love alliteration like this i mean at least title wise it looks good
right we're not gonna use this word in the script because i'm probably gonna end up forgetting it's
not said like with the tea god damn well if we're gonna make this group work we have to convince
them we actually hang out there's no uh wait i honestly think we can get away with it but
we're gonna have to learn some i don't know i don't know how to phrase this so the whole point
the whole premise of this plot plot is it's japanese you can't use the same rules as english
me i can't even speak english it doesn't it doesn't count let me be ignorant in my Scottish ways
a fucking poor emi whenever i've written a like something for her for some reason i always
spell stuff horrifically wrong thank god she can correct on the spot when she's reading a script
but i'll always like the biggest case is so she had to say the word kitty that begins with a p
and instead of a u instead of a u i put this so her sentence was like um my juicy
and i completely fucked up and i didn't catch it and thank god she could change it in time um
because some people read over my mistakes because they're like oh that's the way strongy wanted it
and then others are like no this is clearly wrong and we'll change it and i'm like thank god
too sundry on the other hand you can do a new alliteration soon no that no this title looks good
because it's got all the t's in it it's trouble in terrorist town oh it's a soon oh my god i just
leaked a collab idea with it indulge i've never actually played gary's mod but um sheebie has
and i really want to get into it because i think that stuff is hilarious moment what oh no don't
say don't mummy me it makes me nervous the title's good oh my god this is how i say it t sundery
all right to sundry that's exactly what i'm saying what are you talking about tct is the og
among us game is actually feels good i want to do that and i want to do prop hunt i've never done prop
hunt before um but it looks hilarious like i can just imagine me accidentally being a mattress or
something like being sideways on a wall and i can't figure out how to change and then they're
just coming in the room and i'm like uh it's not what it looks like and i'm like skedaddle
right well if we're gonna make this right so the whole plot is basically we need to form an after
school grip club so the so then we can be left alone to our own devices but then eventually
we find out you like asmr and then we do asmr on you whilst kind of bullying you so for those who
like a bit of bullying but not too far it's not like we don't like it's not like we like you or
anything like that kind of shite aye that's this kind of thing to to sundry's trouble you to tingletown
okay oh i always wanted to learn how va's make script oh it's it's an absolute nightmare um ignore
all of this so that this is oh shit i should lay out properly so this is what acy's gonna see
see she's gonna see this and then we're gonna do soft spoken in the middle of the mic please
because we're just gonna talk like normal at the start okay so this is what emmy's gonna see a
big old warning sign that goes i'll be squiddin me right now i swear god this is makeup such
sensational sense you asunder a sister seek to soften your sulk and soul oh no even brian
doesn't say the tea thank you raven for the tip brian doesn't say the tea say again brian
are you squiddin me right now such sensational sense you asunder a sister seek to soften your
sulk and soul no how does brian know it but i don't
how does brian know i'll give brian my tip fake weeb oh no i'm definitely the gamer
over a weeb i think someone asked that in marshmallow i'm so sorry a while ago someone
asked who's um brian studied as japanese honestly um someone asked who the biggest
weeb is and who's the least weeb the ranking of weeb i think goes azura and then emmy and then
mersey then shebe then me however the gap between shebe and me is astronomical i have such little
anime under my belt i mean if you guys want to watch anime together i wouldn't mind um if if it's
a short like 12 episode only kind of anime we could probably just spoon it out in one day um
i wouldn't i wouldn't mind that i'd be down for that the gap between me and shebe from weeb to
gamer by is like massive like i am just by far a gamer i've consumed an astronomical amount of
benti um i used to be a puddin addict so that's kind of where my exposure really comes from um
i know that's gross but it's just the truth so it is what it is that's really my exposure
to the japanese weeb culture um i i mean i was like into i mean i'm still in a hatsunumiki like
what a vocal miki hatsunumiki um um and like vocaloid i'm in a vocaloid quite big um puddin
what's that a what addict yes yes um i used to actually um yeah i used to have quite the
collection and then my pc became corrupted hmm i wonder why anyway puddin is still around
i closed so then i gave it up but then it opened up again apparently but i don't want to start again
because i got very i used to get very like i used to be like right what's uploaded what's new today
right let's get today what's recommended this week like i use every day i used to be reading
one-shot dojins and all of those puddin read along stream when no seriously uh puddin
is a unique website i do not recommend typing in oh my god she's literally me oh i was daily i
was at it i was going fucking feral for um what is it called right so take emi's lore so that was
like the tag the main tag was emi's lore but then it had to be like oh what are those japanese
tables called where it has the tablecloth that goes over it um so like you're hidden underneath it
those plots i used to froth at the mouth if i used to get some of those oh i used to go
absolutely ape shit um i used to go fucking feral for that i just brainwrote on that shit
yeah the warm ones yeah yeah yeah i read the english dojins
um uh kotatsu yes not to be confused with
i don't know any any was that katsu katsu yeah chicken idea for a future stream watch out emi
oh i'm not being funny but if the girls allow me when it comes to their donutons to commission
one-shot dojins i'm gonna go absolutely feral on that stuff emi plot the alabama or the kandu
where's the candy on emi
emi's albima
tonkatsu chicken
kotatsu warm table
um emi is both emi's candy wait am i being dumb
um oh lollipop got it no um i never particularly seek that out um i used to be really into
bottom i don't know why i really loved um i guess i just really enjoyed the height difference
and all that jazz and like the motherly aspect um he means the lollipop yeah i figured it out
i got there in the end okay right we've written one sentence of this ace more collab that's
probably not i'm gonna well if we're gonna make this group work we have to convince
the teachers the teachers we actually hang out i hope i honestly think we can get away with it
but we're gonna have to learn a little bit about each other so we don't seem awkward or non
interactive with one another when we're in class or walking down the halls through i don't know
american schools always portray the hallways as like never fucking ending and like a lot of stuff
occurs a lot of stuff non interactive non net on a non interactive i don't know i'm sure there's
better word i'll fix it later as i said when we write the stuff live i'll fix it later when i come
back to it which line is the start that ac lets you go through the phone
ac hasn't gone through the phone yet ac is gonna yank the phone you know her posable claws are
quite good for yonking shit it yeah classes can be really far apart literally all the time
like american shows like uh it takes 20 minutes to get to the next class and it's like what how
was that efficient for anyone at first they yank the main hall in my high school was 400 meters
long the fuck you mean non interactive non interactive oh wait isn't that going e that's
what i said non oh do you drop the e oh because an e before i unless something something i've
already forgotten the rule but anyway that's english for you it's cost efficient for companies to
build a school like that
yeah i have classes that were like five minutes between it really wasn't enough time
oh i bet you the teachers were like where were you then and it was like walking from one classroom
to another and they probably never expected it i like learned about hall passes as well we must
learn a little bit about each other show me what color you're and i need to go on to the next
freaking script we haven't even we we haven't even add on add on i'm begging you just bust one out
okay clear your mind clear your mind because this is clearly there's something going on that i'm missing
well how how did you do that even i even i am not in a position to do that at this moment in time
i had classes that were three hours apart rip that
why do you think he's asking you the claw already lost to the script
oh stop that's funny that's funny i seen stroney look at each other the best way to get
know each other 92 minutes of kiss and say right i'm gonna progress to the script because you guys
are made distract me well if we're gonna make if we're going to make this group work we have to
convince the teachers we actually hang out i hope we can get away with it but we're gonna have to
learn a little bit about each other so we don't seem awkward or non-interactive with one each other
with one another when we're in class or walking down the hall i will make that english at a later
date because i don't think that's english the question is what do we even do right now i mean
at least we managed to reserve this classroom maybe something as simple as 21 questions
question mark i hope that's not european quit with us i guess that's a good start um what would ac ask
i'm just glad we don't have to take an extra class so i guess i'm thankful you were willing to
join us in this scheme it's not much of a scheme is it
oh wait how do i make you
hold on i can do this right now itchy girlfriend i can do this right now i'm so smart hold on
how do i do it i can do it hold on hold on no i don't want to hear myself please don't
how do i make you a mod mod mod mod mod mod mod i'm a moderator congrats you can now do everything
you could possibly want wow it's i wonder if me and uh itchy have a have a collab coming out soon
tm hmm hmm i wonder how curious i wonder if i just need to record my lines there we go now we can
see you that's a little better i'm honored oh i was not gonna fucking see you in the chat she can
do it apart where she cannot if she gets banned i hope there's a mod he all better behave itchy
girlfriends lurking around in the shadows okay i guess that's a good start uh also the the the
collaborating uh nepotism damn straight nepotism the fuck i fucking bombed into her dms i was like
hey how's it going i'm strongy cutles from uh veal or you want to do an ASMR collab sometime
and she was like yeah she was like no absolutely no complaints was like yeah fuck it let's go
and i'm like oh shit oh shit we doing it let me go let me go get the script run done real quick
uh she sent me her lines so i need to record mine and slap it together and before you know it
there's gonna be a collab out behold power what do you use to rip scripts on i said that wrong
but it came out right i use google docs super easy simple my first ever script read oh wait was that
the first part did i take your your ASMR cherry your ASMR collab cherry i keep it everyone's like
i've never done a collab before and i'm like what aren't people like fucking begging you for like a
cheeky ASMR collab what the hell oh my god there's no way
hi strongy hi chat and you come and you come we're currently writing a script of that is about
ac and i being kind of to sundary esque but then we discover that you have ASMR and then we kind of
bully you for it but then we end up doing it because we were like oh this is actually kind of fun
xd that's that's the script plot if you want a summary of what what what do we do now i guess
that's a good start i'm just glad we don't have to take an extra class so uh i'm thankful you're
willing to join us in this little scheme maybe you aren't so bad after all maybe you aren't so
oh wait no i can do ac's voice hold on
maybe you aren't so bad after all dada now run another train on me in guild wars hill
if you aren't so bad after him
hmm well i already know your name and all of that stuff so how about i ask you more
personal question oh my god you sound like drake you're like shit
oh actually
an apple in a box are you not in control of your breathing at all times or am i going crazy
that actually sounds like dracula so that's so bad she literally said previous and called the
inner russian oh my god that's not until sunday the ac impression it's i can hardly impersonate anyone
at this stage you know breed manually thank you for the tip apple in a box i know an apple in a box
you've got the correct uh english because it's an an if it's uh oh oh my god you're so smart
shawnee sounds like adam sandler is dracula from hotel transylvania
stop i want to suck your blood i guess that's a good start i'm just glad we
don't have to take an extra clip oh my god no i do
maybe you aren't so bad after all shit oh my god i heard it no ac i'm so sorry
well i already know your name and all that stuff so how about i ask you more personal
questions and then i'll do a little oh sorry if you saw that i'll do a little wink
um well winky face
asking personal questions of the vtuber model would be really good for the roleplay
ah but it takes so long to do what you're asking for i mean actually wait no these are one-on-one
collapse so i could probably be ours to do it one question ah ah ah two question ah ah ah
i'm feeling defensive did i get you data how should i get right conduct
like what like what you keep listening to this on your phone of yours yank oh wait are we gonna
just jump into it you're always on your phone now that i think about it what exactly are you
yankers so okay and then and then and then say yank i say don't worry she snatches
the phone out of the listener's hand dot mp3 i think i'm gonna have to make some folly sounds
folly literally like some sort of like slap or something have you seen the sesame street count
song can cut censored no the muppet demon's got strong e2 now getting oh i mean as a static girl
looks at you and asks personal questions she records oh i've never really done that before
i wouldn't mind giving it a bash honestly i honestly wouldn't mind giving it a bash you're
more than welcome to suggest any uh suggest johns and marshmallow sorry i'm slapping the
fuck out of my hot war but can you hear that sounds like a roast pig right okay she snatches
your phone out of your hand wait what is this are you an ASMR watcher and then yes smack it yeah
that's right we've got my hot war ball wait what is this are you an ASMR watcher and then she's
gonna laugh at you a little bit so that that one goes out to the humiliation bro she's gonna laugh
at you a little bit i never i never thought you were like that i thought you were a proper man
i thought you were a proper man i said a bit of humiliation just shove it in there real quick
uh i never thought you were like that i thought you were a proper man
with good taste but looks like looks like like you are a bit more of a deviant than
i first thought
wait so when you're on your phone all day long you have this playing in your
earphones is it earphones i don't know which cali do you have this playing your earphone
are we allowed to backseat script right hell yeah there is literally no point in time that you are
not allowed to backseat me some people don't like backseat gaming or whatever me fucking help me
i'm clueless i've no got clue what's going on true can we get ic phone tappies yes you most
certainly can wait so when you're on your phone all day long you have this playing in your earphones
strange strange i i wouldn't i would never have assumed you seem so you seem so
normal well maybe liking asmr doesn't mean you're not normal but i don't really
i well maybe liking asmr doesn't mean you're not normal but i personally wouldn't go around
making it obvious i get tingles i don't i don't know i think bullies might pick on you if they
were to find out remember we are high school students so obviously we care about what the
bullies think oh the bullies someone please think of the bullies oh the bullies any bullies
where the bullies around these parts again these are drafts i am most likely gonna fix the absolute
crap out of them offline i can't i can't think of this stuff off the top of my head for too long
i'm boozy yeah you're the bully or you want to get bullied because i can make the girls say whatever
you want you don't really watch asmr so instead put you like listening to asmr
hmm wait so you're on your phone all day long you have this playing in your exchange
i would never have assumed you seem so normal well maybe liking asmr doesn't mean you're not
normal but i personally wouldn't go around making it obvious i get tingles i don't know i think bully
uh wait so am i is this
i think bullies might pick on you there so i guess you uh no more guessing what did you say
is that why you shivered randomly in class yesterday i picked up on it but i didn't want
to say anything because i thought i gave you a jump scare when i texted you this after school plan
in all honesty in all honesty um have you ever tried giving the 3d or what really i have um
i'm actually gonna upload all those videos on twitter when i get a second to breathe unfortunately
things still haven't quite settled down behind the scenes um we might need to hire a thumbnail maker
but i don't know i don't know how much like thumbnail makers cost or like not it's not like
draw a whole new thumbnail it's like no take these pngs of all the girls take the game they're playing
and then give us a thumbnail okay like i i think we might need to post that we need that at the
moment um and then it frees up a lot of um jobs behind the scenes no no make one of your thumbnails
mass producing thumbnails that's super easy to learn i don't even know if there's like a
going rate for it or like is it like you pair you pay per thumbnail i don't know that's a lot
if this character a zoomer why use jump scare oh wait what the term jump scare
i'm sorry i'm not following jump scare is a generational term am i being dumb pay them
and in me strongy makers that's terrible that would be hilarious agency exposed for paying
contractors via audios audios of a unique variation i picked up on it i didn't want to say
because i thought you gotta jump here and then this is where a a phone tapping ASMR
wait so if i do this it might make you shiver all right i'll have it we do it like that you
keep shivering and then we're as like spurs us on to do it more to you and like have a giggle with you
i think that'll do it if so we discover you shiver with ASMR because some people have like a
visceral reaction if you will and their body goes like and then it spurs us on to actually try hard
as well because it's so entertaining but then eventually we're like um okay this is getting
weird now we need to go home smile how about she reacts to the listener being nervous as he's gonna
unlock the phone with her taps no so we've just taken the phone off the listener and discovered
that they like ASMR so we're kind of discussing it a little bit without being too details with it
so if i do this it might make you shiver wait that's so cute is acl out to call you cute even
though she's an adorable one get a kick from teasing huh yeah what are you going to do about it huh
you're gonna cry you're gonna ink
exactly you having a rake ago cute nose no boundaries barriers of course
it's roleplay let her let us have her call as cute yes okay phone tapping is that wait if i do this
it might make you shiver wait that's so cute i just realized i'm gonna have to get ac commissioned
with her big paws in this artwork it's gonna be it's just me being chilling in my outfit next to
her and she's got a big claws on can we get ac to whisper sucable yet in our ears honestly i'd be
down for that uh lollipop whisper sucable yet in your ears for half a half an hour ASMR when
the phone looking small in her paws exactly so this is how people script interesting well
college was so strict whenever it scripts i'm in communication oh this is like please do not think
this is how actual people write scripts this is how my brain processes and slams stuff down
it is a it is a complete nightmare the only way my brain can like slam this down like when i send
this to emmy for example what i do is i highlight like her words as well so she knows what she needs
to see um etc like this is not professional in any way shape or form i'm just showing you how i do it
and you have to take everything i do with a pinch of salt because ac sph big paw humiliation
honestly that's so cute i want to write that um wait so if i do this it makes you shiver
wait that's so cute do it again and then so this is where ac is kind of figuring out wait
wait wait you huh so it can't be done over and over again do i have to switch it up like how
they do in the videos no i'm not going to bully you over this i am genuinely curious i don't
i don't think hearing sounds would ever make my body jerk whoa make my body shiver the way
you just did there how about that you remember that weird ass song
you're a jerk you're a jerk jerk jerk are you squid me right now brian then suddenly out of nowhere
they started making all right yous are actually fucking done and on thank you for the tip for
folk sick for folk sick no um this is totally how people write scripts it's just they go through
infinite revisions with co-writers and editors yes what you're seeing is basically what a draft
looks like but i will be honest there's some stuff doesn't really get changed that much but like for
example the emi collab i need to extend it dramatically but i also don't want to give
emi too many words to say because then it becomes like a nightmare to record you never like i i would
highly recommend never giving more than a thousand words that is becoming a very intense collab
now with the nature of emi at ic's collab with me because we're doing soft spoken we're actually
about to do whispering next which is even worse on the voice so give me all the words it's okay
oh shit emi's here for the challenge um but in general for a collab partner you do not want to
overwhelm them like there's nothing worse than you know being like oh i'm so excited to do a collab
and then you turn around and give like over a thousand words and it's like what the fuck this
is gonna take me like so long to record and so long to edit to give you the correct lines um
yeah i usually write out the first like an outline first with the key phrases i want and then end up
yeah that's the way i do it i'm just intro middle ending shiplash yeah she's also really young so
many words are dangerous for her oh what did he say i've already written over one key words for
my collabs oh no well i mean my i always try and do them tiny but like as i said if you want
us to do like a collab with me and you and me obviously you can just give me whatever you need
because yeah that's not a problem but uh in general um i would say try and no i just i mean
then again emi's fucking collab like absolutely cooked i think it's approaching like 30 case
viewers which is insane um which is absolutely doing fantastic so maybe i should shut my trap
and take a note out of emi's book huh huh you ever thought about that strawny huh huh do you have you
okay sometimes you think of a banger lane and then you write a script at the same time it's
fun to have parts in the skill play emi going hard it's fine you can take breaks from speaking
when yours are to make it okay you're all done you're all fucking done fighting the demons again
um i have a really i have given really long one sister only sister i'm sorry what
oh what did he say
shocking behavior honestly i love my hard-working daughter emi the hat that hat is in the merch shop
the merch is we've got standees we've got keychains and we've got hoodies and trusers if you want
trusers don't don't be afraid to support the merch because it means we get more merch later smile
if the merch is supported now smile is there a preferred length to asmr um now so i've got a
collab coming out with uh right you know what dempo the dempo collabs already out me and dempo
only actually had about five minutes of speaking but the audio is 15 minutes extended because of
the plot i wrote whole merch whole merch it's coming okay i need to i need everyone's stats
to be up just a teeny tiny bit and then i'll contact uh the uh location i love dempo i rigged
shut the fuck up she told me she drew it and got it rigged you rigged her model
that's insane i did not know that lore no way i freaking yanked her tentacles she gave me her
tentacles for a collab it's really hard to see in the video but i have tentacles on my back
yeah me and dempo are a model birth and dream team oh my god that's so precious
he did fantastic yeah i like i went to dempo i was like is it okay if i can borrow your um
i can i borrow your tentacles for this um collab and she was like yeah here take
off and i was like she needs a looking good i'm very proud of those tentacles yes
wow oh my god it's like a family reunion in here god damn
yeah i know the collab with dempo was a hooten holler honestly um
etchy and dempo bret well when you put it like that she
right so we've done phone tap and let me highlight it just so we know i mean i think ac makes sense
to do like nail kind of related stuff like because you know she got big massive clothes
mommy needs tentacles uh wait until i get an alternative outfit okay i i think uh i'm definitely
gonna have tentacles coming from somewhere and it's not my tailbone but it's somewhere behind me
mm-hmm
oh maybe i should make the tentacles green like your legs riefling and imply that i have sat on
you oh okay we're developing that i said what said eldritch priestess nah
um nope nope around the back not the belly button i should have
um ultra killer reference when i don't know what ultra killers i'm so sorry forgive me
reeflings become your plug yeah i think i want to do something like that model wise
even if it's just a toggle because i wouldn't have the tentacles out all the time but i think
it would be very nice to have like your tentacles like wrapped around my legs and stuff and that
i think that would be really cool that's just my opinion anyway reeflings stuck in her ass
how did she sell it no no because i was gonna get that commissioned that would be so sick honestly
for example there are more or less around 200 tentacles right now
can never escape the spelunking allegations honestly right we should make a bit more progress
do i have to switch it up like uh how do they do in the videos oh actually i have terrible news for
any reefling that is currently waiting for the membership asmr stream i'm gonna have to cancel
it because i'm not very well today um i do apologize if anyone's holding off i swear
god if any reeflings been lurking waiting for that asmr stream please forgive me i'm doing it later
in the week okay i'm sorry forgive me forgive me i i'm going to finish this stream and redirect
into sheepsters when she's up because i'm not very well um but i did get her asleep so i'm
doing better but um i've i've got i've got a few things i've got a deal with yeah before my dad
gets a um and unfortunately i'm not in the best health right now but that's just me shebe's live
right now okay don't worry dumb dumb honestly i was afraid you weren't even able to come today
on stream that's my secret captain i come all the time that's absolutely terrible stop it stop
talking stop talking okay uh well a sheepster's live right now i mean she i'm not even i'm not
even being funny we've not even finished like 50 of a script it's just it's just not undone
all the way down but to give you an idea of how you write a collab script like the mersey
two yandere's take care of their human pet i'm gonna turn it into a sleep aid because i think
it'd be cute if we're like snoozing together i'm gonna be like chainsounds.sfx fucking rope sfx
i don't know shuffling soft breathing like all that jazz that's a long ass script no no no it's
five collabs it's five collabs it goes emmy and then it goes icers uh icie here and then it goes
mersey which is two yandere's tied you up because you guys want scottish yandere
i you like that i bet you do uh azure uh goddesses i get upgraded to goddess status um i'll work on
it i might come back and do something different sheepsters two office ladies uh and you do overtime
i think that's a really good title um and then basically oh my god you look so tired
you have confessed you have not slept at all oh no we must pamper you at once asimar continues
listener falls asleep all is good in the world amen yeah
they give her all the love and she's just down atrocious shake in my head my head
yes yandere's johnny is good i thought i was the only love of your life what do you mean is
any like my accent what do you mean and you don't find it intimidating are you no scared of me are
you no fear of what i'm going to do to you if i catch you with another girl that's what i thought
so sit down senpai and take it like a good boy yeah that's what you want
a scottish yandere who would want that definitely release date when question mark i don't know when
the girls will be available it sounds like emi's absolutely tag teamed up the wazoo doing asimar
scripts asmar collapse so i'm gonna let her cook for a bit there's no major rush on these as i said
like i think there was just straight up hoping to move out so is mercy um before any of this stuff
this is this is just kind of goofing off and showing you what it's like congrats on 9k oh
i o seven videos now yes but thank you so much for all the support and the subscriptions
it's kind of crazy honestly freaking nine percent of the way to a play button
and like all i've been doing is farting about on kids games and shit and being like yeah this is
games amazing yippee shawnee do you believe that your wreathlings are in fact mingen no i'm the
mingen one here the reason why you guys have tentacles is to clean me up you need any liquid
possible and i will offer you my nasty pheromone maxing liquids okay i said what said i love every
second of it oh yeah but yes that's the behind the scenes unfortunately my brain isn't working
which is why this has taken me two hours to write not even a full script lol and i get
super distracted and you guys wouldn't stop freaking tipping saying and now they make out like
stop it honestly these are winding me up successfully and i didn't get wind up that easy
the sentence just stun locked me well you don't like when you find out that you're
fucking vtuber hasn't like shivered in a couple of days is a greasy mop bag uh it's pheromone
maxing out the wazoo beo maxing out the wazoo you don't like that are you squidding me right now
i poor thank you for the dollar my dollar now i'll take that dollar as a tip for my amazing
script writing sniffer talk to me again when you don't shiver for a month i cannot go that long
holy crap i like i would say i draw the line at like day five i'm like brove brove i draw the line
at day five sniffer mo you want to sniffer mo because i won't shut up about my pheromone
fucking maxing okay let let me entertain yo right hold on let me redirect successfully into shiver
a bit of cheeky sheebie cotton bum she is going absolutely crazy in elden ring i cannot wait to
watch along uh when i can because i know she got one hand um yes pheromone maxing
thanks for the stream no thank you for letting me fucking blab your bloody ears off
about how i make scripts that aren't really technically scripts but it is what it is and
thank you so much to the members that understand about the delay in the asmr thing are you squidding
me right now excuse me smells extra fishy today smile excuse me excuse me
thank you i can't believe i have to thank you for the fucking money after an insult like that
thank you your free papa for saying that i'm extra fishy the day i thanks i yeah yeah
all right then i see how it is i like fish excuse you i right then
you'll eat out now you should be wanting to pour lemon on it yeah yeah yeah yeah i see how it is
deep inhale um all good your work way ahead of the pack small delays are fine yes i just need to
breathe a little bit okay um i just need to breathe a little bit and unfortunately it was
really bad time in that i planned the asmr collab it collab asmr membership stream hold on let me
check the community oh shit okay i guess after spiral we'll be doing it okay oh apparently my
new short about taxes came out is that my hair in the profile picture is that my shell that's my
shell i can see that we are so back thank you i can i can see the shell in your profile picture
that's my shell that's my hair you got me as your profile picture thank you
okay i'm still waiting on confirmation as there's emotes are coming through and then it's my turn
for emotes and then we go back to whatever the missing moat slots are okay we are so back in the
best name oh it's the best name i've ever read reeflings love seafood especially
take a bath and let us drink the stock oh my god fish stock unironically always prefer the lemon
i didn't i don't know if i said the last time when i was like i'm absolutely stinking i'm gonna go
for a shower i can't remember what stream it was honestly it's every stream uh i ended up brian
strongly don't shower i love that stink can we just ship it that is putrid thank you gaming kitsune
for requesting my stank be mailed to you via a can that is putrid uh that's terrible clam slam is
still my favorite phrase from you oh i need to do a lot of blessing back in elden ring when we
pick it up again can we get a veal or stank tier list so everyone thought mersey was the stinkiest
because she like made reference to something and me was like sitting behind the scenes like
i haven't showered or washed in all these days and i don't even wear deodorant behind the
sea like because if i don't go outside what's the point of wearing deodorant uh and i'm like the
pu allure agatius imagine scented candles that's i've actually seen that there's like this brand
that collabs with v-tubers on scented candles i'm like oh my god that's hilarious you're per mate
oh no i showered for her i wasn't gonna freaking she only comes in that's the second time i've ever
had like someone come in and clean for me but it's just because my dad's coming and i just don't
have time for anything like i had that eight hour sleep yesterday oh my god i have never been so
happier to pass out my beloved stinky pheromone maxing oh she
oh it's disgusting um ha why am i so tiny oh is anyone
that one's for you baby um yes eight hour sleep will keep you sane and creative yes i don't know
if i'm gonna nap so the only problem with that eight hour sleep fix is i am not awake in the
middle of the night to to record ASMR because it gets really loud uh because of traffic and stuff
during the day it's just not possible do you wash your sheets often enough probably should do a bit
more i'm not gonna lie i'm nasty look i don't i i know some people are like they'll come on and be
like oh i'm a nasty v-tuber i don't wash it after a day tee no i'm like no i'm fucking nasty like
i'm disgusting i'm i'm the meme that's disgusting i'm actually like i can see i'm getting bad
just sell the used sheets and buy new ones no because i sleep naked as well like my bare sweaty
arse like on the sheets and that eight hours keeps you alive i would buy the entire stock of
strawny scented candles strawny's just a nasty girl for literally you know some vtuber like
i forget to shower it's like no i'm fucking nasty i've got bio i've got greasy mop which means
greasy hair um thankfully i'm good at brushing my teeth so at least my breath isn't stinking
so and he's got skid marks on his sheet no what i have like the clean i shower after a
shit but i've not been shitting properly sorry this is getting foul this conversation's getting
foul i've been so constipated that i'm not pooping anymore and i put i shower after i poop right to
like clean my butt properly and all that like i'd be jamming that bar soap up there and everything
that's disgusting i'm making this conversation worse i think i should just end the stream i'm
not explaining myself well long and story short i want a japanese bidet at one a japanese toilet
for the bidet at one point learn it a lot but i'm sorry i'm sorry she wants to take down the
board to cease the allegations that'll come after now's the time to make the conflation
a roleplay because you look the part what what does that mean that bars up my tent will call for
real for real at power wash in strone's hall do you think i could contact the power washer
people to get a dlc of us that'd be good watch their sales skyrocket wink wink
you're the female version of asmongole absolutely not no there's some of the horror stories i have
heard one of them was that he would spit blood and wipe it on the wall no no please elaborate
what about how i wash my butt after i poop i never feel clean i don't know if you guys have
a big butt but i have to stand up to wipe sometimes thank you for the tip for all the legend i don't
know i don't know if you guys stand up and wait but my butt cheeks are quite big so i have to stand
up and wipe sometimes i can't sit down and do it it doesn't work because my cheeks are so big
so i have to go for a shower as well well i stand yeah that's why i'm like i want a japanese toilet
the lord thickens honestly i always squat it doesn't make me clean no i just get a shower like
i'll wipe and then i'll just go for a shower strone i can't the giant fucking dumpy strikes again
the big dumper problems can't relate i stand my stand wiper oh shit i think this is getting to
i think i need to shut the fuck up yeah he had ginger vitas and he would wipe his bleeding
gums on a wall yeah i remember i was like oh i was like even for me that's a bit so your cheeks
are so big you have to stand as kind of um yeah this is a bit too much i'm right okay okay well
let's wrap it up we'll redirect into sheebie who is definitely not talking or articulating about
any of these types of conversations um she uh tell me you brush your teeth no i actually have no
problems with brushing my teeth i genuinely have no problems flossing etc um so i'm quite happy
to report in on that it's just the pheromone maxim no wonder you can give a round of applause
with them chief thank you be a little lover that's hilarious i can i'm actually gonna try
and reupload that on youtube because it only got taken down because i breathed in the ear at one
point so i'm gonna be a cheeky shit wait my warning expires on september 19th is when it expires so i'm
gonna cut the end where it time stamped i'm just gonna completely cut the end off and see if i can
upload that or not um okay thank you so so much for the absolute cursed ending to the script
right in stream um but yes i am very thankful for helping me write these collabs i'm glad you
guys enjoyed the behind the scenes kind of seeing what it starts like it doesn't necessarily end
like this but i could probably show you a finished collab script like i'm sure dempa uh would be
comfortable with me showing what i sent her to record um all that thingies um that's why they
did it oh yeah um the noise of me clapping without my hands wasn't offensive or against the rules it
was me breathing in the ear when i did it when i leaned in it said like around the 10 minute 58
seconds or something i breathed into the microphone and did it and that's what got me taken down so
dempa is spreading the ice toy call actually is she oh i would do it if i wasn't on a warning
my fave streams are these in real life talks oh god i love the script streams thanks thank
mommy literally though um thank you for the stream no thank you for bing chilling bing chilling um
i i'm gonna get going i'm gonna get some rest in the tank and i'll see what happens i'm like
shutting down right now i can feel it and i'm like but you've just had eight hours sleep so why are you
shutting down but yes thank you so so much i will talk to you good forgivers tomorrow we are doing
what tomorrow we are doing fall guys oh my god molly player game and then oh my god we're playing
fall guys i hope you guys have downloaded that so you can stream snipe me bro you're in a sleep
honestly do you need us to wash anything before you say no everything's clean because i had to get
a maid which is really lovely honestly i like her i ironically love these unhinged just talking
throughs oh god okay please download fall guys or the jelly bean game because we're playing it tomorrow
i will give you a quote on screen and then you can join my lobby and you can touch me and stuff
if you really want it as a jelly bean but yes i'm going to redirect into she be please remember
she be is not down for backseat gaming unless she asks that's my only request as i thrust you
reeflings and potential snowberries pinpals snippets maybe even a bleeding heart here or there back
into the action with she be on elden ring okay thank you so so much i'll see you good for
goober's tomorrow and as always please prepare your lips okay all done see you goofy goober's
tomorrow bye reeflings bye see you tomorrow as you stream snipe me around the game
and no seriously stream snipe me bye bye